[Music]
hi everyone welcome to eyes on
enterprise I'm Stephanie Wong and today
we're talking with Brian Dorsey
developer advocate for compute and we're
gonna be talking about how to approach
cloud infrastructure for enterprises and
how to decide where to deploy your
workloads we have a multitude of options
on Google cloud and so it can be a
challenge to optimize for things like
scalability performance developer
experience so Brian thanks so much for
being here thanks so much for having me
this is one of my favorite topics so I'm
really excited that's great to hear
so first off there are lots of options
on compute compute engine App Engine and
cloud run and enterprises they have a
lot of legacy systems and a lot of
dependencies in place like message
brokers databases web apps so through
the lens of an enterprise how should
they make that initial decision
absolutely yeah it gets complicated we
have a lot of different options and
enterprises are complicated things so I
think I like to think about it as kind
of an abstraction kind of a layer cake
almost where at the bottom you have
things like VMs and then you kind of
move up and up in layers as you go so
you've got things like kubernetes or
cloud run and App Engine functions and
do they get more abstract as you get
kind of closer to the top and I think
enterprises also they're big right so
you end up often running multiples of
those things together to solve the same
you know in the same system to be honest
I think a lot of enterprises face this
challenge of feeling like they're gonna
make the wrong decision and they need to
make the right decision from the get-go
so how do you help them make that choice
to dive in and not feel like they have
wasted time and resources investing in
the wrong infrastructure option yeah
that can be really scary right you know
like all this effort and if you just
change things later so I think there's a
few things we can do you can kind of try
to lower the risk and there's some
technical things that we can do that I
think running software and containers
really helps with that nearly all of our
computer environments support running
software that's running in containers I
think that's true for most the other
environments people might be using so I
think that helps a lot also you know you
can just decide not to move it right you
know you've gotta have into existing
systems maybe you know like one of my
favorite definitions of enterprise is
where most of the software it doesn't
have an engineering team on it at all
you know it needs to keep running it
means to work but it's the ops folks who
are like trying to keep that going and
there I think VMs are really used
and you know once you have some of your
software running in cloud you're trying
to make a bigger system out of it so you
started trying to glue it together and I
think that's where serverless and things
like that can help okay wait hold on
server lists so everyone has a different
definition of server lists even at
Google we have varying products under
the server list
ecosystem so help us define what that is
here in this case I'm not gonna do it
like there's so many definitions as
therefore less I think it's little
tricky but for the purpose of this
conversation let's focus on the kind of
pay for use you know like the actual you
do some work and you'll pay for only
that work I think that's the the core
definition is there isn't how I go to
help
this covers yeah I mean wouldn't you
argue that that pay for use model
applies to compute engine too though
kind of um so when we're talking pay for
use we're thinking of the actual work
being done and compute engine and our
VMs and several other things in cloud
you kind of reserve you paying while
it's on verbally so you're paying for
the reservation and you might not be
getting any value out of that it might
just be sitting there idle so there's
things you can do to to minimize that
and you want to do that but the
serverless stuff is designed so you're
only paying for the actual work being
done ya know a given HTTP request
or responding to a message broker or
something like that right so it's more
event-driven you have the potential to
scale down to zero things like that
exactly that yeah okay so let's just
talk about these abstraction layers in
order if you don't mind going through
them totally you have kind of functions
as a service and you know our thing
there is cloud functions and you know
from a developer this is a developer
tool primarily from the developers
perspective you write this like small
piece of code a function and you kind of
pushed up to Google Cloud and you know
we do all of the work of running it it
responds to an event like you say
earlier or you know that might be
something coming from HTTP or from a
message system does a little bit of work
maybe a side-effect maybe not and then
returns that's it so what makes server
looks a good fit and like when would it
be something that's more of a constraint
for people so it's showing up in lots
and lots of spaces so I think people are
exploring all the use cases so you know
consider that but some of the places
that are especially strong is in kind of
gluing systems together where you you've
got a bunch of existing pieces and
you're trying to make them all behave
like they're one system
and also in a lot of kind of message
flow kind of scenarios where there
people are doing either kind of data
transformations or they're moving
information from one system to another
things like that is where it shows up
the most for for this level of the
abstraction that function side right and
then besides cloud functions and and
cloud run we also have our long time
managed service from 2007 app engine and
that's been great for developing web
applications and the like so can you
explain what App Engine is and what it's
used for specifically yeah so App Engine
it's a wider view of the code you have
like a full code base it's still a code
focused kind of environment and you push
that whole code base it's kind of it's
really meant for hosting web apps
primarily and so you have your kind of
the different URLs you respond to and
the different code that that handles
that and it works as one piece so you've
got the code kind of host a database
pieces and the same kind of idea you
have an app you push it to Google it
runs it scales it up and down it's
really good for things where it's really
bursty you know where you can't really
plan for the usage and you need to be
able to respond but also not have a
bunch of infrastructure sitting there
idle when you're not using it right and
I can imagine with retail online shops
that are expecting huge bursts during
events like Black Friday things like
that exactly that
all right so working our way down the
abstraction layer cake we have cloud run
can you tell me about what that is
absolutely so it's kind of trying to
make the combination of the containers
world and the server this world and give
you kind of the best of both so from a
container side it lets you run any
software that will run in a container
and can listen to an e and a web request
HTTP requests our events come in that
same way and server list so you get to
pay for what you use and only what you
use you get this hosted environment to
run anything you want basically
so cloud run yeah it seems like it's
something that developers have been
rallying for for a while now they want
the portability and the flexibility of
containers but they also want the
agility that serverless gives them
absolutely so we've mentioned containers
a bunch of times already what is it
exactly let's talk about that okay so
from a technical standpoint there's a
bunch of things you could say we're
usually talking about docker containers
under the covers they're really like
actually a tar.gz a zip file of some
files practically though I think it what
it does is it solves the works on my
machine problem right
like where like something worked in one
environment but doesn't in another but
worked on my machine like it so it just
makes things much more consistent
wherever you're running them I think
that's the the key takeaway for
containers so for those that are already
running a large number of containers
what would you recommend them to deploy
on yeah I mean I think that's what
kubernetes was invented to help with so
you know it's basically service a system
set of tools open source environment for
running lots of containers across lots
of machines but with the idea of
treating instead of thinking about
individual containers or thinking about
individual computers your thing about
the application as a whole or like
micro-services you mentioned earlier and
how they fit together and how the pieces
talk to each other and managing all of
that communication as well as the
containers themselves and insulating you
from the actual you know physical or
virtual hardware they're running on
right so that brings us to gke or google
kubernetes engine exactly tell us more
about what that is used for yeah so
kubernetes is an open-source project and
it helps for this runs in a lot of
different environments and google
kubernetes engine is taking the
expertise that Google engineers and the
SRS built you know building this up and
the longtime experience of running
software at Google to make a hosted
version of kubernetes where we automat
you know we handle the upgrades to the
software keeping the masters online
things like that and basically let you
focus on the application even more than
you would you know none of the covers
it's running on VMs and the rest of
Google cloud but you don't to worry
about that it's just kind of all handled
it's up if you want to make it larger or
smaller there's no you can turn to to do
that sort of thing is there any kind of
opportunity for those that are running
their workloads on App Engine to move
over to kubernetes engine for example
yeah and in fact you know basically kind
of all up and down this stack you know
most of the environments allow you to
run software in containers so that's
true from App Engine cloud run
kubernetes and and VMs you know compute
engine we talked about a minute so once
you get into attain or you can move
things around pretty smoothly all right
so on gke what are you good use cases
for and what are some of the constraints
yeah so it makes this insulation layer
so that is a good example so if you need
to run the same Apple
in multiple different environments so
this comes up you know for like devin
test and prod for almost everybody but
you can also see it come up you know
with like for writing game servers for
example you know you you need to be able
to run in different legal environments
we're talking enterprises here right and
large companies have legal specific
policies they have teams that are
responsible for different parts of the
systems you need to be able to plug your
system in to the other things that
already going on the enterprise and
kubernetes is especially good at that
it's very modular and you can connect
your different enterprise pieces in at
every level from authentication to
policy about firewalls you know all the
way up and down the the stacks and get
the different teams who are responsible
for those involved and and working at it
at the kubernetes level yeah are they
just for performance and also just
optimization for you utilization of your
computer source --is how does it affect
that yeah so the utilization is the like
the key phrase there like that's the
reason everybody cares about containers
at all like so you can run more software
on the same machines exactly and you
know that's what containers are for and
you know honestly why Google cared about
it like you get more running on the same
same hardware and the same thing there's
true in cloud as a whole you know in
cloud utilization usage you know cost
money so you know if you can optimize
there it saves you money and hopefully
time as well yeah so we just talked
about gke and some of the performance
and cost optimizations that you get with
it but I mean I want to talk a little
bit about that low level of abstraction
compute engine yeah you know if you see
a lot of flexibility you can take care
of everything that you deploy on the VM
like software and any installations that
you have on it so when does it actually
make sense for you to choose compute
engine yeah so this is it's one of my
favorite services because it underlies
so much of the rest of cloud for one you
know gke you know his intern running on
top of compute engine our managed
databases are and I think it's
especially relevant for enterprises
because you have so much software that
doesn't have an engineering team on it
right you need to keep it working and
almost always the best first step for
that is to to it may already be running
in a VM and if not to move it into a VM
or move it into a cloud VM and you can
usually do that it's flexible enough you
can usually do that without
having a change hardly anything because
it is a computer it's a virtualized
machine so you can run the same things
you've been running out of places
so you mentioned software that needs to
run without a developer team supporting
it necessarily all the time yeah so give
me some examples there like any stories
that you have oh yes I mean like this is
I think this is like classic enterprise
right you know you've got you've got the
team that builds it and then they have
to move on and build the next thing and
build the next thing in the build the
next thing so even in-house software
tends to not have active engineering on
it but also you're buying or renting
software from other places that needs to
work third-party software you have to
keep running and then you know there's
there may just be some old stuff where
like you don't know the history of it at
all yeah there's that thing that like
nobody quite knows how to redo but needs
to keep working right and all those I
think are a good fit for running on vm's
yeah yeah I think we've all have been in
that case where we're working with
software but the code base is so old you
know it takes so long to make changes
and you know maybe it's not the best fit
for deploying in a containerized
environment right now yeah so like for
anything where you know it's not the
right time to kind of make changes to it
right you know the VMS are a good place
to start so we just went through the
abstraction layer cake as you mentioned
and you know with there a ton of options
we just cover it so once again like to
kind of wrap our heads around this how
do you make that decision part of it is
just this abstraction like how do you
want to be working as a team and if your
team is mostly developers that's gonna
keep you kind of hired to abstraction if
you're mostly kind of ops or have deep
integration requirements or existing
things you're mostly gonna be on kind of
the lower levels there's also some kind
of technical constraints it's worth
checking the docs to make sure that
these specific things you need are
available in each of the environment and
then I kind of mentioned team a little
bit but I want to double down on that
what is your team most comfortable with
what do you care about the most what do
you need to do and want to do as a team
and I think that may also kind of affect
things there the other piece that is
maybe not so obvious is just kind of
where in the life cycle it is you know
for things that are newer you had to
have the full range of options and I
encourage people to start high on the
abstraction I think I'm kind of go down
if you need to for existing systems
you're usually going to be kind of
working your
from you know other VMs or containers up
kind of from the bottom right alright so
we talked about so much but what can
people do to actually get started on
some of these yeah I think um yeah there
are a lot of options and I think if you
know if specific ones of these jumped
out you're like oh that's what I need
you know go dig into that a little bit
look at the docs we have code labs on
each of these for what it feels like to
actually use and get started on if you
want a bit more information we did a
much longer talk on the same topic and
you could kind of kind of take a look at
that and kind of go from there but yeah
give it a try like think about how this
works for your applications and what
your challenges are and and we're adding
some of this in is gonna really help out
yeah I think the important point that
you made earlier was you don't actually
have to move all your stuff to the cloud
you can pick and choose the ones that
make sense and then think about which
layer of abstraction makes the most
sense for your development teams alright
Brian thank you so much for being on the
show I encourage everyone to check out
Brian's talk where he dives into much
deeper about some of these topics and
again join us next time for eyes on
enterprise
[Music]
you
[Music]